many different ways i can introduce this
next guest die hard minnesota sports fan
good friend of the program he's in the
wrong missy which is available on
netflix starting tomorrow wednesday
may 13th but quite frankly uh
i've never had a guest on this show
prior to whom the previous guest said
you got to ask him
to tell a good fart joke as chris
jericho said
on the way out the door moments ago in
advance of hearing that nick
schwartzon's on the program
and here he is on the program how are
you nick
hi rick how are you i am well nick how
are you sir
um i'm uh yeah i'm here
i it's such a funny question everyone's
like what's going on it's like i
you know day to day with this insanity
and you tell jericho i'll break a chair
over his head
yep i will time i see him i'll fart on
that chair first
you know what
giving the people what they want right
there exactly
yeah it's bizarre man how are you doing
i am fine you know we're we're coming to
work every day we're healthy we're
you know the situation that you've been
here before so you know how far away
from each other we all are we're
socially distant enough to continue
doing this thing so we're going to do it
you know
that's where i am good for you man thank
you you know and then we were talking
about the last time that you were here
uh it was a week later than your
scheduled appearance
uh which you called into to say hey i
can't make it because i need to stay in
minnesota
to continue the flow that clearly i had
because my friends think that where we
are sitting uh was the reason why
the vikings beat the saints and then we
all saw what happened uh with the 49ers
so that was the last time yep yep that
was last time rich thank you
you know what so you who's more who's
more superstitious you were sandler
who's more superstitious when it comes
to sports nick
uh i would say me for sure
a hundred percent i i'm way more
superstitious
i mean that game oh god now that game is
back in my head rich
sorry i've got to sit here and
quarantine
with another memory of that and that
49er team was so good and somebody
pointed out
i didn't realize this but um if the
49ers had
won their parade would have been right
in the start of that
this whole storm yep so they were like
gosh
if the 49ers had won that might have
been catastrophic for the
for the city yes there is apparently
like an actual um scientific proof
that because the the parade was in
kansas city which was not nearly as
overrun by covet 19 as as san francisco
was at the time but
you know that that that that that was a
kansas city thing but you know your your
minnesota vikings had a tremendous draft
nick
would you agree i don't know but this
whole season is so
weird it's like you know i i
uh it's just so frustrating i don't even
know what to think of it the draft was
phenomenal
but you know it's it's like having
halloween
and getting dressed up and being like
okay we can't go trick-or-treating you
can't go out and go anywhere
but you can get dressed up you know i
know but just not yet i mean it's
entirely possible
nick it's it's feasible um that you do
see justin jefferson
they're gonna have the season right yeah
i mean that's the idea i just
nobody knows brother but it is one of
those things too that you you see the
the kids that we have up on the screen
right here that the vikings drafted and
you you could see how they all get
you could see how you know they you they
plug in and and suddenly
you know uh your guy kirk cousins can
actually lead this team to a a bigger
year
than last year yeah it's it's it's very
exciting
it's just it's just so bizarre i think
that they should have
games here's what i think okay yes nick
i can throw this
out there you have the game and then you
invite
10 fans but they're 10 of the most
belligerent
and drunk fans and you spread them out
in the arena
so those are the only people that you
hear
during the game so you just play and you
just hear
those people from philly from all the
towns
just the loudest loose cannon fans
that's all you hear echoing
through the stadium i think that would
be pretty interesting you know what nick
uh i like this uh idea let me pull on
this string a little bit
um and continue this thread um because i
was just talking about how into the
voice i am
what if you make it like a competition
and
america votes america votes
the least obnoxious fan off
and each week by week they're invited
back to the game
in a more belligerent and drunker
fashion and then we eventually crowned
the
worst most idiotic fan in america
what do you think of that i love that i
think that's phenomenal rich
i i want to be a part of that and it's
not called the voice it's called
it's called the vomit
carson daley could still host it yeah
you know carson we might have to twist
his arm
and and work shop it a little bit
that would be phenomenal you know i
think i could make a run at that one
now uh in terms of the draft nick
schwartzen here on the rich eisen show
you as a vikings fan
how much did you love the jordan love
selection
by the packers oh my god
i mean that was that to me
was phenomenal just because i mean who
knows what's going to happen if
he could be phenomenal you know what i
mean but right just the fact that there
was
you know upset in the green bay
universe and confusion and anger that
just brought me so much joy
so that was that was great i mean yeah i
mean
and old man farve got involved too so
you know
um this is something that's a nice
ticking situation down and
uh or across across the way in wisconsin
that you've got to be loving
you got to love that oh yeah oh yeah i
love it i love that far
through in his two cents too because
he's just sitting there
just just laughing and just loving it
i'm sure
i was supposed to do a commercial with
him i was so bummed what do you mean he
got pulled what do you mean
uh they called me to do this online
campaign for uh it was a gambling thing
for
legal gambling and uh they called me up
and they're like hey do you want to do
this campaign i'm like uh
i don't know what is it and they're like
it's you and brett farves
and i was like yes yes i do
and i'm like where do we film it and
they're like well brett
wants to film it at his compound in
mississippi
and i'm like oh yeah how do i how do i
get there
and they were like you have to take
eight flights
then there's a catapult and this is the
whole process
i was so on board though they're like
yeah i'm like am i staying there and
they're like yeah
i'm like oh come on i am so down
like in farts in my bizarro
football and you're fine in the [ __ ]
but they said they might revisit it well
i mean for so for illegal gambling huh
for legal gambling legal gambling yeah
okay
good lord just tossing some brews and
some wranglers
running around the compound and leaving
leaving something behind so you can go
back do an old leave behind
uh nick schwartzen here on the rich
eisen show hey tell me about the wrong
missy
uh that you're you're in that you back
how many how many
how much have you done with spade and
schneider rob schneider the gang is
getting back together in a way again
here
yeah it was pretty cool man i i mean
in terms of what we've all been in at
the same time i mean
we've got to be at about 10 films and uh
this is perfect timing for this movie
it's a crazy hard r
romantic comedy and it's just it's just
a good break lauren laffys plays missy
so it's basically
spayed those two women named missy one
of them he went on a nightmare date with
and he texts the other one that he's
going on a company corporate retreat
and he messes it up and texts the wrong
missy this trick is kind of a disaster
and she shows up on the airplane and
then comedy ensues from there
comedy ensues me lauren spade jackie sam
is amazing and schneider and it was
great because
there's one scene with me and rob and
david it's just us in a hotel room so
that that was a blast
just to have us three going crazy with
each other
heavy on the crazy with schneider's
character
and uh yeah it was a blast man it was
super fun i mean david's
so dumb so it's hard to
interact with him but you know we tough
it out we make it work
right and and who's the best athlete
actor you've ever been around nick
give me that one before i let you go oh
athlete actor yes that you've ever been
i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to say
dame judy dench
a lot of people are sleeping on her
but she is well-rounded
close second jeremy iron that's odd
that's um i don't know this just sounds
so obnoxious for me to say but
i i honestly sandler is
just so deceivingly good i mean
what it turns out what i played with
it's not like we play like oh
we've got lunch break let's play pick up
football you know what i mean
or oh let's just jump on this baseball
diamond that's sitting here
so in terms of just athletic abilities
sandler's basketball skills
uh are really shocking so
how intense are these games nick we're
seeing in the last dance some very
intense practice footage from the dream
team all the way to the
last dance documentary how crazy is it
that i was in it did you see that
were you in it nick oh my god i thought
you were gonna bring that up
there's a shot it's b-roll random b-roll
of chicago
and they do a sweep of state street and
i was doing a show
at the chicago theater and i'm on the
marquee i'll text you the screenshot
okay and it says nick sorts and many
smells to her
and it's just it's really quick but it's
it's there my phone blew up
it is so absurd
and i swear to god i'm not lying at all
it's literally
in the documentary well that's a great
new claim
i'm a part of it that's a new clue just
a slight bit more than dame judy dench
has been a part of it yeah and her great
game so
so sandler how intense is he is he very
jordan-esque intense
demanding on the floor and on the court
just like uh jordan
nick yeah yeah he he goes there air
sandler
will go there and uh it's pretty
it's pretty crazy and spade is probably
the most unathletic
he's pretty much air ball and he sits
out any game that we ever play
so that's on the opposite spectrum spade
is
probable judy dench probably is faster
literally in any capacity there was a
scene in the wrong missy
this is not a joke yes where the scene
just called
the lullabied was called for me and
spade
to jog past a pool
and um we were like okay and then david
could
couldn't jog what do you mean and he
goes let's just he goes here's the deal
um do not jog and i'm like what do you
mean he goes
just speed walk and you can't go past me
so let's just speed walk but look like
you're jogging
i'm like that is the dumbest thing i've
ever seen
and people will notice that we're not
jogging and he goes i know
that's why just act like you're jogging
so we
we do this thing where we're running in
slow motion it's like slow motion like
chariots of [ __ ]
charts and yeah but they're trying to
look like we're
grunting and the director's like cut
what are you doing and i'm like i
just throw spade under the bus i'm like
yeah i don't know
this was david's choice and the director
was like you're not even running you're
not even jogging
that looks so weird and so we had we had
to force
david to jog
one take he's like we have to have one
take and we did and then david collapsed
on the lawn he was like
huh that's crazy is anybody
i was like oh my god well i can't wait
to have david on friday and ask him
about why he can't even jog past the
pool for two seconds
that'll be a great conversation i can't
wait to hear what he says
that was a good coach man he definitely
yeah it'll push you to the limit i bet
i'll push you to the limit nick thanks
for the time brother
you be well you hang in there you be
safe okay
hey always you guys love you hang in
there and uh let's
let's do it football and the vomit let's
get let's get on that show there you go
i'm knocking on wood knock on what if
you're with me that's nick swartzen at
nickswartson on twitter and at neil
rick's
nick swardson on instagram right here on
the rich eisen show and the wrong missy
is available starting tomorrow on
netflix and david spade will be on
friday's show to talk about that and
more
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here